we have countries that you are just a
hundred percent tax on a product and
when that product is sold by them to us
we brilliantly charge them nothing and
people say oh that's free trade no
that's stupid trade that's really stupid
trade that's a technical term that's
president Trump promoting his plans to
renegotiate trade deals and bring
factory jobs to the u.s. he was talking
at a White House event highlighting
products made in America
the president's trade policy includes a
threat to tax importing steel critics
say that could lead to a global trade
war targeting products from the American
heartland like orange juice dairy goods
and whiskey mark Strassmann is in
Bardstown Kentucky where distillers are
warning against a Bourbon backlash mark
good morning good morning if you love
bourbon this is heaven heaven he'll the
world's largest privately owned and
operated bourbon maker in warehouses
like this there are 1.2 million barrels
of aging American whiskey just at this
one distillery but suddenly this
industry's growth market which is
overseas is a growing worried aging well
is what Bourbons all about had no
question America's native spirit is a
survivor it outlived the whiskey
rebellion the Civil War and Prohibition
95% of bourbon today is made here in
Kentucky but increasingly enjoyed around
the world places 4,000 miles away like
65 and King a bar in London the Bourbon
sales are spiking it's undeniable
there's no question people abroad love
bourbon Fred Minich a bourbon authority
wrote bourbon the rise fall and rebirth
of American whiskey for the first time
you have foreign markets that are
getting the opportunity to consume
bourbon and what that has done it's
created an eight point five billion
dollar industry here
Bourbons overseas market alone is now
worth one-and-a-half billion dollars if
President Trump imposes tariffs on steel
imports the European Union has
threatened retaliatory tariffs against
specific American products like bourbon
the Europeans have looked quite hard at
what might hurt most Viki price is a
British economist who follows the EU and
they have found one that they believe
would have emotional appeal and maybe
therefore change the mind of President
Trump why target bourbon the EU is
serving up a stiff shot of hardball
politics straight up the majority of its
made in Kentucky well who's in Kentucky
Senator McConnell you know they're gonna
press where it hurts Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell's home state of
Kentucky voted for President Trump by
almost a two-to-one margin last November
17,500 people work on distilleries along
Kentucky's famed Bourbon trail and some
of them could have jobs on the line I
mean it seems to be a bit of an irony
this is a uniquely American industry and
yet that American first policies could
come back and bite the industry there's
no doubt that president Trump's trade
policies could hurt bourbon the job
growth has been unlike anything else in
Kentucky and if we start seeing tariffs
come on to bourbon I really think that
bourbon jobs could be lost all of his
bourbon has to age at least two years
some of it for 23 years
so another trade war worried for this
industry is counterfeit bourbon cheap
liquor made overseas with the name
bourbon slapped on the side Norah
all right mark thanks let's hope that
doesn't happen this is a great American
industry indeed but it's an elusive
question how do you get fair trade yeah
you see the consequence is our largest
trading partner as well as Europe